plus de volaille française pour
l'angleterre
des rumeurs dans bourse et les
nationales isabelle monte en flèche
hussein de jordanie à la veille qui
voyage de claude cheysson au proche
orient
bonsoir le système d existe aussi pour
l'espace c'est paradoxal mais c'est
aussi rassurant voyageurs de l'engin
spatial qui est passé tout près de
saturne avait perdu ses yeux c'est à
dire que ces caméras étaient tombés en
panne et bien par erreur un technicien a
bousculé la machine sans le vouloir et
tout est reparti un petit peu comme le
coup de pied dans la machine à laver en
panne
mais ce qui est fascinant cette fois
c'est que les manoeuvres se font à des
milliards de kilomètres de distance
les explications de georges leclercq qui
lui n'est qu'à quelques mètres derrière
moi et oui hélas hervé mais voici
maintenant la plateforme de voyageurs
qui est tombé en panne c'est un des
constructeurs qui nous la montre est qui
et qui montre comment on doit piloter
toute la journée d'hier les techniciens
et essayer de réparer cette plateforme
en panne panne dont ils ignoraient
jusqu'à présent même la cause chance
incroyable à des techniciens appuyé par
erreur sur la commande qui fait tourner
la plateforme dix fois plus vite que la
normale
et ô surprise tous des blocs mais on ne
sait toujours pas si c'est l'ordinateur
ou la mécanique est en cause en
attendant voyageurs a rempli à 90% toute
sa mission voici les gros plans des
anneaux de saturne photographiée hier
là encore des mystères et des surprises
comme les anneaux en pulsations là où
avant il n'y avait rien bref une moisson
extraordinaire très vite la nasa espère
réparer complètement voyageurs 2
qui s'enfoncera alors vers l'infini
janvier 86 il visitera uranus et ses
anneaux ténue trois ans plus tard
neptune autre planète géante située aux
limites du système solaire notre
ambassadeur de la fille n'y aura alors
accompli une des plus belles missions
d'exploration que les terriens et jamais
lancé 1,7 pour cent c'est le chiffre de
la hausse des prix en juillet ce n'est
pas une surprise puisque l'insee avait
déjà laissé entendre il ya une dizaine
de jours ce chiffre n'est pas une
surprise non plus puisqu'on savait que
l''indice de juillet devait intégrer la
hausse des tarifs publics et celle des
carburants surtout ajouter à cela les
augmentations des prix alimentaires les
fameuses hausse sur les lieux de
vacances et vous aurez ce résultat 1,7
pour cent conséquence immédiate le smic
sera automatiquement revalorisé au 1er
septembre
le taux horaire va passer à 17 francs 34
c'est à dire 3 7% d'augmentation cela
porte le smic à 3017 francs par mois
pour cent soixante quatorze heures de
travail
mauvaise nouvelle pour les agriculteurs
français ceux qui produisent des oeufs
et de la volaille
les anglais veulent interdire à partir
du 1er septembre
l'importation de volailles et 2 sauf
ceux qui viennent du danemark d'irlande
ou de suède le prétexte une nouvelle
politique sanitaire pour combattre une
maladie appelée la maladie de newcastle
la maladie de newcastle
elle a disparu de nos élevages depuis
1976 affirment les aviculteurs
et il ajoute cette maladie c'est un
prétexte les entreprises françaises sont
plus performantes nos prix plus
compétitifs
la bretagne par exemple possède une
production de haute technicité proches
des lieux d'abattage d'où des prix de
revient très bas nos voisins par exemple
commercialise 25% de l'ordre d'un an des
coûts nous en commercialisons 90% des
coupes
ces chiffres reflètent bien notre avance
technique les britanniques ont un
réflexe protectionniste déclare le
ministère de l'agriculture à paris c'est
un coup porté au marché commun fin de
citation
les aviculteurs france elles sont
d'autant plus en colère que depuis
quelques mois il s'était passé à
l'offensive offensif qu'on pourrait
appeler dinde de noël française dans
tous les foyers d'outre-manche les
bateaux avec leur cargaison de dinde
devait commencer à partir début
septembre vers l'angleterre
la coïncidence des dates est frappant
cette décision britannique pourrait
avoir de graves conséquences pour les
producteurs de certaines régions proches
de la manche producteurs plus
spécialisées dans l'exportation vers la
grande-bretagne nouveau cri d'alarmé
d'andré bergeron pour l'unedic et
l'assurance-chômage le numéro un de
force ouvrière s'alarme pour le déficit
de cet organisme
demain un conseil interministériel vent
tout cas s'atteler au problème comment
fonctionne l'unedic et comment arriver à
équilibrer ses comptes
martine gilson l'unedic c'est une grosse
tirelire rempli par trois sortes de
financiers les plus gros pourvoyeurs les
patrons ils verseront 80 24 milliards de
francs ensuite bhl et à 17 milliards de
francs dernier pourvoyeur les salariés 6
milliards de francs
total des recettes pour 81 47 milliards
de francs
le drame cette année c'est que les
dépenses s'élèveront elle à près de 53
milliards de francs
résultat un trou de 6 milliards environ
cause du déficit
l'augmentation du nombre des chômeurs
indemnisés il était près d'un million
400 mille au mois de juillet dernier
contre moins d'un million en juillet 80
pour combler le trou il n'y a pas 36
solutions
la plus facile serait de majorer les
cotisations des salariés et des chefs
d'entreprise cette majoration
susciterait le tollé et des syndicats et
du cnts
style aussi de penser à une
participation plus grande de l'état sur
le problème
le budget n'est pas extensible à merci
troisième solution l'emprunt andré
bergeron en a lancé l'idée
le cnps et pour la cfdt contre et
jacques delors nier semble-t-il pas
favorable autre solution réduire les
dépenses sans diminuer les prestations
on pourrait retirer du budget de
l'unedic
les dépenses des pré-retraites près de
20 milliards de francs
problème on alourdirait d'autant les
dépenses de la sécurité sociale
dernière hypothèse trouver de nouveaux
cotisants et l'on pense immédiatement
aux fonctionnaires une recette comprise
entre 4 et 5 milliards de francs genre
où le ministre du travail est plutôt
pour anicet le pors ministre de la
fonction publique ne veut pas suivi en
cela par la cgt en revanche fo et la
cfdt elle ne l'exclût pas le conseil
interministériel de demain va passer au
crible l'ensemble de ces hypothèses il
est probable qu'il ne tranchera pas tout
de suite
en attendant l'unedic ne mettra pas la
clé sous le paillasson et les chômeurs
continueront d'être indemnisé à la
bourse nouvelle flambée des valeurs
nationales is able il s'agit des actions
des sociétés comme rhône poulenc par
exemple que le gouvernement va
nationaliser prochaine
depuis trois jours il y a beaucoup
d'acheteurs pour ces titres la bourse et
le résultat c'est que à la surprise
générale en trois jours donc la cote de
ses actions a grimpé de 20% à la base de
tout cela philippe sassier des rumeurs
concernant les projets du gouvernement
sur l'indemnisation des actionnaires
mais ça des rumeurs ou ne manquent pas
et la bourse adorent ça elsa autant
qu'on aime les femmes otages dans les
salons de thé mais ce matin la
correspondance économique qu'un journal
spécialisé a sorti un texte qui serait
le projet de loi concernant les cinq
grands groupes nationalisa bhl réaction
pincée de matignon qui n'apprécient
guère ce genre de fuite et qui dit c'est
un document de travail parmi tant
d'autres il ne préjuge pas des décisions
qui seront prises mais depuis vos
marchés hervé on sait bien que les
rumeurs ont la vie dure
et puis le jeu en vaut la chandelle la
capitalisation c'est à dire la valeur
des sociétés nationales isabelle en
bourse représente plus de 30 milliards
de francs et on estime à environ 5
millions le nombre des français qui
d'une façon ou d'une autre ont intéressé
par la bourse bon mais alors
mais tant qu'il n'y ait pas de fumée
sans feu qu'est ce qui intéresse les
boursiers dans ces rumeurs peuvent aider
le problème numéro un
dehors de toutes les autres
considérations économiques et
financières et comment indemniser les
actionnaires alors le gouvernement a
déjà annoncé qu'il n'y aurait pas
spoliation ce qui fait que les titres
des nationales isabelle remonte depuis
quelques jours elle était sous côté et
sans entrer dans les détails il y a eu
une phrase dans le texte publié ce matin
qui a retenu l'attention les actions des
nationales isabelle seraient transformés
en obligations dont le taux d'intérêt
serait égal au taux de rendement des
emprunts d'état à taux fixe sur le
marché secondaire alors je vous accorde
que ce jargon administratif et financier
des pas très poétique il était remis dit
que cela signifie que ces taux qu'ils
étaient dix au fait allusion sont
actuellement élevés et que donc il
pourrait avoir une bonne opération à
faire pour les porteurs d'actions des
nationalisations compte actuellement
pour ses actions les yeux de chimène
pour rodrigues
c'est un petit peu trop beau pour être
vrai nom d'à côté peut-être qu'elle cela
pour deux raisons la première ça
coûterait cher à l'état et donc aux
contribuables chaque année donc rien ne
dit que cette formule sera véritablement
retenue deuxièmement quelle sera la
valeur nominale c'est à dire le prix des
obligations là tout dépendra de la
période de référence qui sera utilisé
pour calculer la valeur des actions est
bien actuellement selon les hypothèses
ça va de 3 ans à 6 mois avec des
variantes actuellement en tout cas on
peut dire que les spéculateurs jouent un
petit peu à la le tri le gouvernement
n'est pas encore tranchée en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que le gouvernement
prépare des réformes pour les parcs
oui d'abord ils s'inquiètent
actuellement de la baisse des nouveaux
dépôts dans les caisses des parts d'une
commission de 10 membres vient d'être
constituée pour étudier les problèmes
général de l'épargné rendra ses
conclusions le 30 mars prochain
en tout cas on peut dire que certains
régimes fiscaux seront revus et corrigés
et que certaines décisions pourrait déjà
être prises à l'intérieur du budget 1982
merci philippe toujours à propos des
nationalisations j'ajoute que le pcf ne
veut pas faire de surenchère c'est ce
qu'affirme un membre du comité central
du parti communiste donc dans les
colonnes du journal révolution il y à un
décalage entre les positions socialistes
et communistes dit il mais nous ne
ferons pas de surenchère nous
respecterons le suffrage universel
enfin économie toujours avec cette usine
alsacienne qui a passé la frontière
elle appartenait un patron allemand
qu'il s'était installé dans un petit
village du nord de l'alsace
wonder chauffe
il vient d'en repartir précipitamment
avec toutes ces machines et tous ces
outils
les ouvriers sont revenus de vacances et
ils ont trouvé les bâtiments vides et ce
n'est pas la première fois que cela se
passe
en alsace c'est l'alsace en effet
qu'avait choisi monsieur moeller pour
installer son usine aujourd'hui occupé
par ses employés mais en fait la société
était basée au lichtenstein fiscalité
oblige et la société mère en allemagne
rien de plus facile alors pour monsieur
moehler que d'embarquer ses machines et
plus productive laissant derrière lui
bâtiment de location est employé ici
nous sommes dans la partie de
l'imprimerie où il y avait deux machines
brimer ses semelles il reste plus rien
non ils sont tous déménagé dans le
week-end alors combien de machines au
total sont partis il y en a quatre
machines en très bonne état qui sont
partis et qui produisent se maintenant
en allemagne a dit bolt
seule trace de ce départ précipité une
lettre de convocation pour le comité
d'entreprise le 31 août à l'ordre du
jour la liquidation de l'entreprise et
des mesures de licenciement collectif
une solution bien cavalière pour se
tenant d'un capitalisme sauvage qui se
joue à la fois des législations des
frontières et des emplois
c'est la tactique patronale je vous
dirais que ils ont maintenant empocher
les primes de création à l'emploi ils
ont fraudé le fisc
donc ils ont ramassé le plus d'argent
possible et ils ont rapatrié les
machines alors en attendant une solution
on continue à occuper nous continuerons
à occuper en attendant une solution et
que nous espérons venir très rapidement
comme nouvelles protestations des
écologistes contre la centrale de la
hague et le retraitement des déchets
nucléaires
brice lalonde a tenu une conférence de
presse ce matin avec d'autres
organisations
il a affirmé qu'en attendant le débat
sur le nucléaire la france pouvait très
bien arrêté de recevoir des déchets
radioactifs d'autres pays politique une
réponse de jean poperen à michel
d'ornano le secrétaire national du ps
estime que l'ancien ministre dans ses
critiques se trompe sûrement de
président puis du côté de l'opposition
l'université des jeunes démocrates
sociaux depuis quatre jours à rennes les
jeunes du cds planche pour mettre au
point une nouvelle stratégie de leur
mouvement dans l'opposition ils ont déjà
reçu la visite de rené monory et de
bernard stasi
demain c'est jean lecanuet
qui clôturera leurs travaux le reportage
de jean michel mercurol et philipp etter
un séminaire politique sous le soleil
d'août les jeunes du cds ont fait
délaisser leur planche à voile à
quelques 400 participants militants
confirment et sympathisants élus tous se
sont retrouvés objectif la poursuite du
combat politique
le cda et le parti de l'opposition qui
va affronter le plus durement et
prochaines élections cantonales à partir
du moment où le plus grand nombre de
sortants partir de nos rangs et que nous
sommes en plus du temps serré ambiance
studieuse ici ou par l'implantation
recrutement formation
méthodes nous ne sommes pas là pour
jouer les revanche électorale dit on
mais bien pour se situer se placer
maintenant ailleurs quelque part entre
l'ancienne majorité et la nouvelle nous
devons prendre du recul à la fois par
rapport à l'action menée par les là le
gouvernement chirac et barre il faut
aussi savoir prendre du recul par
rapport à l'action menée par le parent
mauroy savoir trouver les les
aspirations des français en dans les
années 1980 et essayer de trouver des
solutions beaucoup plus concrète
beaucoup plus propre des proches des
français
lorsque vous avez fait part et le texte
que vous allez ainsi rue dans le journal
électoral que vous êtes en concevant
résolument moderne cds technique de
l'ordinateur pour rédiger les journaux
les tracts les fichiers mais bien faire
connaître son message les jeunes
démocrates sociaux le savent cela passe
aussi aujourd'hui inévitablement par
l'épreuve du magnétoscope en effet des
planteurs chacun s'exerce devant les
caméras aux phrases courtes et
percutantes entraînement intensif parce
que les jds les moins de 35 ans du cds
sont les forces vives du centrisme très
vite ils seront directement versés dans
la politique active
ils seront quatre candidats responsable
pour eux l'échec électoral de mai ne
sanctionne pas du tout la faillite du
centrisme la décentralisation du style
c'est l'exemple même d'une idée
centriste 1 complètement reprises par
les socialistes
autrement dit il s'agit moins maintenant
pour le cds recherché l'initiative ppte
l'ère de renouveler son langage et
d'approfondir son projet police nous
sommes dans l'opposition maintenant nous
ne sommes plus tenus par les contraintes
du pouvoir et bien l'opposition doit
être l'occasion de sorte de pèlerinage
aux sources de réfléchir sur notre
doctrine d'approfondir notre doctrine et
est de savoir comment nous amène à nous
situer par rapport aux problèmes
d'aujourd'hui par rapport aux
difficultés de notre temps par rapport
aux aspirations de nos concitoyens c'est
par un retour à la doctrine que nous
allons affirmer notre présence et je
l'espère rayonner notre message et non
pas du tout par jeune tchèque l
initiative spectaculaire venant de je ne
sais où
confiant avant tout en ses propres
forces
le cds veut aborder sereinement ce qu'il
appelle sa cure de rajeunissement dans
l'opposition charles fiterman contre les
codes en ville c'est une surprise mais
le ministre des transports a estimé tout
à l'heure à titre personnel que les cas
dans ville était une absurdité il va il
va se concerter donc avec les autres
ministres concernés pour envisager leur
suppression charles fiterman a fait
cette déclaration au cours d'une
opération de prestige pour la sncf avec
en vedette le cévenol un train qui relie
paris à nîmes puis à marseille par le
chemin des écoliers ou plutôt par ses
très belles régions du centre de la
france charles ferré fiterman 2010
transports étaient dans le train avec
trois autres membres du gouvernement et
il a aussi réaffirmé que la sncf ne
fermerait pas les petites lignes
l'actualité à l'étranger avec d'abord
l'irlande du nord peut-être un déblocage
dans le drame des grévistes de la faim
d'un côté margaret thatcher le premier
ministre britannique pourrait faire des
concessions aux prisonniers catholiques
républicains
par exemple sur le droit de porter leurs
vêtements et puis de l'autre côté les
prisonniers eux-mêmes limiteraient leur
mouvement mais margaret cette chaire a
toutefois refusé de recevoir leur
représentant le député owen cajon en
france aujourd'hui il y a eu plusieurs
manifestations de soutien aux grévistes
de là
irlandais à paris par exemple vous le
voyez sur ces images
la cgt a manifesté à rennes aussi une
trentaine de militants cgt ont retardé
le décollage d'un avion pour londres
la france est le problème du
moyen-orient demain claude cheysson le
ministre français des relations
extérieures sera en jordanie première
étape d'un voyage dans toute la région
le roi hussein de jordanie est à paris
il a rencontré les dirigeants français
il sera notre invité dans quelques
instants
en direct depuis sa résidence parisienne
aux côtés de paul nahon mais auparavant
des explications sur le roi hussein et
la position de son pays dans le conflit
du proche-orient hussein roi de jordanie
depuis 1955
un homme dynamique excellent tireur il
se sépare rarement dit on de son
revolver
quand il est à mme il a failli être tué
en soixante dix au mois de septembre
quand les fedayin palestiniens ont
déclenché contre lui une insurrection
qui fut durement réprimées cette
attitude lui attire l'hostilité des pays
arabes qui le considère alors comme
l'allié le plus sûr des occidentaux en
1977 lorsque anouar el sadate entreprend
sa visite historique à jérusalem visite
qui va déboucher sur les accords de camp
david
hussein perçoit la menace que la paix
séparée égypto israélienne s'est posé
sur son pays il pense que le règlement
du problème palestinien risque de se
faire sur son dos par la création d'un
état dont la capitale pourrait bien être
à man u scène opéra lors en retournement
spectaculaire de sa politique
il rallie le bloc des pays arabes qui
refusent les accords de camp david le
front de la fermeté et le 3 novembre 78
à bagdad
on le verra au côté de celui qui fut
longtemps son ennemi intime le président
syrien hafez el-assad depuis lors ses
relations avec les usa n'ont cessé de se
dégrader et hussein a même entamé un
flirt avec l'union soviétique
sur le plan intérieur il a réussi à
maintenir le calme en faisant participer
les palestiniens à la gestion du pays au
dehors
il a recouvré tout son prestige dans le
monde arabe et il a d'excellents
rapports avec l'ol paie invité de notre
journal donc le roi hussein de jordanie
majesté vous venez de rencontrer à paris
la plupart des dirigeants français alors
je voudrais vous demander est-ce que
vous souhaitez une initiative française
ou européenne
dans le conflit du proche-orient et
donnant expect je ne mange pas une
initiative de la part de la france ou
l'europe mais j'espère beaucoup d'autres
dans notre partie du monde
ce que l'europe et la france vont
continuer mais qu'elle contribue à faire
une contribution juste et durable dans
notre partie du monde et notamment en
définissant guingamp des principes
importants et composants les fondements
de cette paix majesty le président
anouar el-sadate et le premier ministre
menahem begin viennent vous le savez de
se rencontrer à alexandrie en egypte
dans le cas des accords de camp david en
jour et vous demander si vous
personnellement vous restez toujours
opposé à ces accords à ce processus de
paix est positionné sache
la situation est-elle des problèmes que
mais le problème vraiment reste vu poser
je ne sens pas que c'est le processus
qui existent jusqu'à présent va pouvoir
résoudre le problème quoi qu'il arrive
d'autres peuvent penser que beaucoup de
progrès ont été réalisés mais moi pour
ma part je pense qu'il ya une grande
instabilité dans notre partie du monde
et ces deux fours du problème
palestinien c'est c'est vraiment le
grand problème de la rive occidentale et
de gérer de gaza et d'autres territoires
adjacents
il ya une injustice créer des subies par
le peuple palestinien qui tout à fait
intolérable est jeune il ya un an qu
deux fils progrès vers une paix est
signé global on ne reconnaît pas les
droits des palestiniens liberté à leur
droit de s'exprimer sur le sol de la
palestine
le problème donc reste tout à fait poser
c'est un problème de grande actualité et
je crois qu'il faut s'attaquer à ces
problèmes que l'on m'a pas fait jusqu'à
présent majesté s'ils vont un éventuel
accord se faisait entre les israéliens
et palestiniens ne craignez-vous pas que
cet accord se fasse contre vos intérêts
propres à savoir et vous le savez que
certains dirigeants israéliens estiment
que la palestine après tout c'est chez
vous elle doit avoir lieu
c'est chez vous dans votre territoire et
prendre le mental et le problème de la
palestine est un problème qui concerne
palestiniens et leurs droits sur l'eau
propre est le seul territoire
l'estonienne sol
c'est sur le sol de la palestine que le
problème doit être résolu les années
possibilités et israël la tva la grille
mais je ne pense pas que chrismaëlle
fils se mettre d'accord avec les
palestiniens
l'expression lorsqu on se dit les
palestiniens accepteraient de telles
choses cela ne peut se faire que dans
les conditions de liberté que dans le
respect de la résolution 242
on ne peut pas imposer par la force la
loi
les palestiniens doivent décider de son
propre avenir en ce qui le concerne les
palestiniens pour la cour palestinienne
ce qui est de rappeler aux acteurs
rendent un grand mouvement une grande
révolte et je ne pense pas que en israël
ou ailleurs ceux qui estiment qu'il sera
possible d'induire en erreur les
palestiniens les détourner de leur
recherche de la paix sur leur propre sol
vont réussir
c'était très brièvement l'arabie
saoudite a présenté un plan de paix pour
le proche orient
que pensez vous de ce plan de paix cette
jeune femme frêle toi je n'ai pas vu de
plan en tant que tel
présenté de cette manière et bien
différentes positions différentes
attitudes ça ou d'expression c'est la
façon dont s'expriment les sauvegardes
d'expression il peut s'agir même de
agressé des arabes mais c'est un autre
exemple
ats les initiatives ont été entreprises
en vue de parvenir à une paix juste et
durable
les shoots b2 caste je pense que ces
questions à m ce sera à l'ordre du jour
de la réunion au sommet des états arabes
respecte pour voir comment nous allons
pouvoir traiter de ce 100 m
nous allons évidemment c'est dans les
détails du projet voit ce qu'il faudra
faire ce qui s'impose
merci merci majesté
en bref dans l'actualité à l'étranger
toujours la pologne
nouvelle polémique entre solidarité et
le gouvernement solidarité hausse le ton
le syndicat de lech walesa menacent de
ne pas ouvrir les portes de son congrès
à la télévision il craint que les
journalistes de la télé officielle ne
leur transmettent pas avec assez
d'objectivité l'iran téhéran a réitéré
sa demande d'extradition du commando de
la vedette à bardine et puis enfin
l'angola le gouvernement de luanda
demande la convocation du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu des militaires
sud-africains ont franchi la frontière
et ont pénétré en angola pour poursuivre
des groupes d'extrême-gauche et tout à
l'heure l'aviation sud-africaine a
effectué des bombardements en angola
jean-pierre viande pour le chef du
gouvernement de pretoria pic botha qui
ne peut nier l'entrée de son armée en
angola
il s'agit d'une opération poursuit
contre des terroristes et en aucun cas
d'une invasion dirigé contre le peuple
angolais
au contraire selon le gouvernement de
luanda les deux colonnes blindées sud
africaines ont pénétré à 200 kilomètres
au delà de la frontière et les combats
font rage autour de la ville de l'ogive
à pretoria aurait pour objectif des
rampes de missiles qui pourrait avoir
été implanté à 400 kilomètres au nord en
fait les incursions des troupes de
pretoria venue de la namibie voisine
dure depuis que l'angola est indépendant
en juin 80 une attaque identique des sud
africains avaient tenté de détruire
l'infrastructure de la swapo le
mouvement de libération d'un ami des
combats bref mais violent s'était
produit avec comme aujourd'hui
intervention aérienne l'ampleur de
l'actuelle opération est tel que
l'affrontement prend maintenant une
dimension internationale
luanda a porté l affaire devant le
conseil de sécurité et demander l'appui
de fidel castro leader des non-alignés
et du kenyan arap moï président de los
rios à quant au secrétaire général de
l'onu courval d'eim il a écourté ses
vacances en autriche pour regagner new
york
enfin si washington déplore l'incident
sans condamner formellement le
gouvernement de pretoria
paris a désavoué une intervention
considérée comme une atteinte à la
souveraineté d'un pays indépendant
alors étant au début d'une vraie guerre
apparemment pretoria cherche un rapport
de force favorable à la proche de
l'indépendance un midi afin de ne pas
être conduit à un tête à tête avec la
swapo pour cela il lui faut donc d'abord
gagner sur le terrain
retour en france avec la sphère de la
tuerie d'auriol journée importante
aujourd'hui puisque le juge
d'instruction entend des pierres de
bizet le grand patron du sac qu'il a été
entendu toute la journée par madame
françoise laurent guérin pour l'instant
rien n'a encore filtré mais il ya une
nouvelle rumeur à marseille on parle
d'autres disparitions mystérieuses
isabelle bechler
l'interrogatoire de pierre debizet chez
le juge françoise laurent guérin se
prolonge au delà de ce que l'on pouvait
attendre selon toute vraisemblance le
juge essaie de faire la lumière sur
l'affrontement des clans m'assieds
contre marjah au sein du sag des bouches
du rhône en effet outre l'élimination de
masquer qui s'est effectuée dans le bain
de sang que l'on sait un autre membre de
ses amis a disparu depuis trois mois il
s'agit d'yves pour toi trésorier local
de l'organisation
mais ce n'est pas tout la police a
enquêté sur tous les membres du sag
figurant dans le fameux fichier remis
par marina m'assieds au juge
d'instruction et il apparaît aujourd'hui
qu'un autre homme a disparu depuis
février 1981 c'est un patron de bar
marseillais de 35 ans claude castellanos
amis de mme astié et de courtois comme
par hasard et selon la police quatre
autres membres du ca du département or
est également disparu un contexte
particulièrement nauséabond qui
expliquerait la longueur de l'audition
du patron du sac
un sondage de france soir et de l'ifop
sur la télévision il montre un goût
croissant des français pour les
émissions culturelles 65 % des réponses
sont favorables à ce type d'émission
sport avec la voile la course autour du
monde elle va partir samedi prochain à
plymouth en angleterre 31 bateaux vont
la disputer et pendant huit mois et
quatre étapes
ils vont tenter d'être les plus rapides
pour faire le tour de la mer à la voile
parmi eux six bateaux français archi des
épreuves de voile la course autour du
monde arriverait certainement en tête
tant par la durée que par les
difficultés très divers ce qu'elle
propose une épreuve qui en est à sa
troisième édition
elle a lieu tous les quatre ans et qui
est arrivé à son âge de maturité
les 31 bateaux présents importe mots
sont tous des voiliers de course hyper
sophistiqué et plus comme en 1973 et
encore un peu en 1977
ebbett de croisière alourdi par des
aménagements luxueux le meilleur mara du
monde sont là tabarly che blythe laisse
les williams cornelius van linschoten
les jeunes nougat bel oiseau poupon et
tant d'autres ils seront donc 31 samedi
au départ trente et un monocoque dont la
taille varie de 14 à 24 m les plus gros
préféreront gagner en temps réel c'est à
dire couper la ligne d'arrivée avant les
autres les plus petits au contraire
viseront le temps qu'on pensait
c'est-à-dire un classement qui prend en
compte la longueur la surface mouillée
la surface de voilure le déplacement et
un certain nombre d'autres paramètres
un classement qui doit en principe
mettre à égalité de chances des voiliers
de taille donc deux vitesses différentes
tous vont affronter les maires les plus
dures du monde celle de l'océan indien
et du pacifique sud
là où il ne passe qu'un cargo tous les
six mois tous connaissent et mesurent
les risques qu'ils prennent
si on voulait c'est irrécupérable parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'avion
les avions peuvent rien faire il n'y a
pas de bateaux et les hélicoptères n'ont
pas de suffisamment d'autonomie
donc à mon sens qu'elle apporte en plus
c'est qu'il faut envisager cette course
en tant que marin premièrement et
coureurs second plan et alain gabet un
méditerranéen qui n'a pas peur du risque
surtout pas devant l'océan a dû plier
devant la police maritime anglaise qui
lui reprochaient d'être sorti du port à
la voile et non pas au moteur il est
difficile de faire des prévisions de
temps pour samedi déjà car la course
part samedi mais laurent bouvier en tout
cas pour l'instant le temps reste au
beau sur l'ensemble de la france
oui encore du beau temps demain les
attentions l'anticyclone qui nous
protégeait s'affaiblit et une
perturbation venant de l'atlantique va
atteindre dans les prochaines 48 heures
l'extrême ouest du pays avant de nous
préoccuper du temps pour demain
regardons les températures celles qui
ont été relevés à 14h par la météo
nationale qui est sont presque partout
en hausse presque partout supérieures à
20 degrés avec même beaucoup de 28° à
marseille à toulouse mais également à
bordeaux à pau et à biarritz le temps
prévu pour demain il est encore beau et
ensoleillé sur la plupart des régions
avec un petit peu de brume le matin dans
le nord et dans le nord-est et un peu de
vent dans la vallée du rhône
attention je vous disais dans
l'après-midi dans la soirée quelques
nuages vont atteindre l'extrême ouest et
ses nuages donneront localement quelques
orages les températures prévues
eh bien elles sont très favorables pour
la saison 26 degrés dans le nord comme
vous le voyez 29 et 31 dans le sud on
est presque revenue aux températures du
début du mois je vous dirai un mot du
temps pour le week end il sera nuageux
sur la moitié ouest samedi avec quelques
pluies
et quant à dimanche et sur les nuages
vont recouvrir l'ensemble du pays
donnant çà et là quelques orages mais
aussi beaucoup de soleil entre ces
orages enfin pour terminer notre agenda
demain c'est la saint-augustin et le
soleil se lève à 7h03 merci laurent
rapidement parce que nous sommes en
retard les résultats du kart et hillel
secours est aujourd'hui à deauville
voici l'ordre d'arrivée 4 10 7 2 et 6
vous lisez les rapports sur votre écran
les rapports pour 5 francs fin de cette
édition du journal je vous rappelle les
prochains rendez vous avec l'information
arabe en fin de programme et puis demain
l'invité d'antenne de midi ce sera
jacqueline maillan passé une excellente
soirée bonsoir